You're listening to radio lab from public radio,W , N, Y, s,
e, n, n, p. R.
[inaudible]
today's show. You ever heard of this? It's about choice.
I don't know what to expect. I believe you're about to see a miracle.
And we thought we would start things off in a parking lot in sunny Berkeley,
California with a psychologist. I'm Barry Schwartz.
I'm a professor of psychology at Swarthmore college where I have been teaching
since 1971 the only job I ever applied for.
So I think deep down in my past I appreciated the value of simplifying one's
options. Even wrote a book about it called the paradox of choice.
And to illustrate that paradox he brought us to, well,
you'll see it very, will you give us a visual as to what we're doing.
So we were about to walk into Berkeley's very famous Berkeley Bowl,
which is a supermarket,
very unusual when it comes to fresh fruits and vegetables. Wow. Has a selection.
I'm like any I've ever seen in my life. Could you describe your first of,
I see just fields of oranges.
So we've got navel orange,
Valencia juice aren't Texas Valencia juice, our organic neighbor,
the old 10 JZ Tangerine have large naval on small phone.
They Redmond at us Moodle suburban and large gala with Washington Pacific road,
Hawaiian plant, those delicious
[inaudible].
We have freedom of choice with respect to every yellow line and you see it in
every area of life in romantic relationships. Marge of Vaginas.
When I was growing up,
the answer to the question should I get married was obvious.
The answer to the question when was which Lez of course, of course.
And as soon as possible. Well now there are no different.
Every imaginable lifestyle is available. You can be gay, straight bi, Zack,
look at the seedless grapes, a late, late, more apples.
The sense that there are a million opportunities for you.
You can make your own rules. The shots overwhelming.
Okay?
Counseling centers,
psych services centers and universities are bursting at the scenes.
Why? These are the most privileged kids ever.
The schools are giving them everything they could possibly want and they are
banging down the doors because they are so screwed up. Why? What's going on?
And the answer is people don't know what to do.
They don't know how to choose.
They can't face a world in which everything is available.
And I see this in the college, it's, it's,
it's heartbreaking to see these incredibly talented college seniors who we
haven't given every opportunity to do what ever they want.
Terrified at graduation. They know that this is a stage in life.
We're walking through one door means they gonna hear a lot of other doors slam
shut. It can't bear the thought that they may walk through the wrong door.
It's choice. [inaudible] it is. It's the disease of of modernity.
This is right. Well this is, come on,
go ahead and let's do the show. But I say come on in reservation.
What do you wife? Well,
because like people from Swarthmore college get to pay like $45,000 a year for
the privilege of do they know that's a very, very rare slice of American. Yeah,
fine. You're right. You're right. Thanks. Come on. You have this too. I mean,
how many speeds on your bike do you really need? Well, that's a different thing.
I mean, I don't need, I don't need 22 speeds. I happen to make do with five.
There you go. So there are some real questions here and I'm this hour,
we're gonna look at choice, choice and decision making. When do we choose?
How do we choose the way? Do we choose the limits of choice, of choice,
of choose limits? What's up Jews on Radiolab? I've Jetta Ivan,
Ryan, Robert Krulwich, Steve at this bitches
know
[inaudible]
okay to begin. Oh, you ready? Yup. He says, let me just ask the basic question.
A basic question, which is, okay, so a lot of choice can be bad,
but clearly we need some choice. So what's the right amount? Actually,
how much can you really handle? Hmm. I asked that question very short.
Well,
there's a classic study in psychology from 50 years ago called the magic number
seven
the magical number seven plus or minus two that's general there.
Author of the book,
Proust was a neuroscientist and the new book called how we decide in the 50s he
says, I think like 1956 a guy named George Miller wondered about this.
How much could a human brain really hold?
So he conducted a series of memory tests,
ask people to memorize different sets of numbers, letters, musical notes.
And what Miller found out is that the average human could hold about seven
digits plus or minus two at any given moment in working memory.
When you say working memory,
you mean like a like what we can keep in our top of mind memory, right?
Not like memory memory, but the like, like Ram. Exactly. Random digits.
You can hold about seven plus or minus two and with practice people can can,
you know, really bump it up a bit with practice. Robert, with practice,
I'm still struggling with six, six, six, six, six, six, six.
And I think myself, I think I got the first floor.
I mean it's not an accident that that so many of these random digits we have to
memorize from phone numbers to social security numbers are seven plus or minus
two. Now,
the interesting thing is what happens to our decision making powers when you try
and get more than seven in your head? What you want me to shut the door? Yes.
Well, let me introduce you to someone. I'm a Baba. I'm a professor here at, uh,
the Stanford Graduate School of Business in marketing. A lot of my research,
it has to do with the brain and tricking people. Oh yeah, absolutely.
So Robert, I wanna tell you about one particular experiment that he did.
So the experiment is pretty straightforward. It goes like this.
You got a bunch of subjects together. He said, okay,
I'm going to give you all a number, your number and a little card.
You're gonna read the number and I want you to commit that number to memory.
Take as much time as you want to memorize the number.
And then he says you're not going to walk to the next room and recall the
number.
And that's what subjects think test subjects think that they're going to be
doing.
So they know they're going to be in one place getting a number of going to
another place with reciting that number. That's right. That's all they know.
That's all they know.
But they don't know is that not everybody is getting the same kind of number.
Some people get a seven digit numbers.
Some people get a two digit number that I can do. By the way,
I think I can do two digits. Yeah, I doubt it.
All the subjects have to do is they've got to memorize a number of walk out of
room one down the hall, have room to then recite their number.
Now just imagine you or me person with a two digit number in their head.
It was walking out of room one two is my number.
I can definitely remember this down the hall.
The same time someone with seven digits in their head,
two to eight walks down the hall.
Now here's where the trickery comes in as they're walking down the hall mid
memorizing all of a sudden skis me,
they pass silly lady in the hallway and she's holding something.
Sorry to interrupt you, but would you like a snack? Um Oh. Oh sure.
She says here have have a snack. Just as our,
as our way of saying thanks for participating in this study.
You can have one of two snacks.
You choose between a big fat slice of chocolate cake or be a nice bowl of fruit
salad. Meanwhile, they've both got these numbers still in their head.
Now here's the weird thing. When they finally make their choice,
what would you like? Some yummy cake or some healthy fruits and the people,
this is crazy. The people with two digits in their head. No, I love cake,
but I think I'll take the fruit. Almost always choose the fruit. It's healthy.
Whereas the people with seven digits in their head almost always choose the
cake. You know the cake? I want the cake and we're talking by huge margins here.
It was significant. I mean this was like in some cases,
2025 30 point difference. So, uh,
the meaning if you have seven digits in your head,
you are twice as likely to truce cake than fruit twice.
So let's get on with this so that people with the seven that just get the cake.
I get that part.
I don't know why exactly that doesn't interest you as to why they would choose
y. Okay, good. Now that I've got your interest, I would tell you the theory,
and this is where it gets interesting,
it seems that the brain is anatomically organized into different systems.
Dual systems is what they're called going to Jonah.
You have a rational deliberative system,
which is sort of more to the front of the brain and then deeper in the brand.
You have an emotional unconscious system. According to Jonah,
these two systems are often at war,
and then there's constant competition between the rational brain and the
emotional. Um, they're always competing for attention, um, and, and, and,
and to guide and direct your behavior,
especially when you have a tough choice like bother shifts, cake versus fruit.
There the competition is fierce.
Emotional automatic system is pushing them towards the cage.
The emotional brain loves sweet and gooey chocolate cake frosting.
That's really what you want your chocolate. Now, on the other hand,
the deliberative system other hand comes and says, wait a second,
that you were thoughtful about this choice carefully.
This probably is not good for you because high fat content.
Think about your waistlines. Think about your cholesterol.
Isn't that good for your help.
It is not good for yourself and that access a check.
But if you give that rational deliberative system, seven numbers,
just seven to memorize, one to two, eight, nine, three, six one, two,
one, two, two, eight, five, one, one.
So two I should coalesced suddenly for the rational range as in you could do too
much to keep track of getting tired. Ooh,
it can't put up as much of a fight. Oh,
she means greater likelihood that the emotions will drive their choices.
The astounding thing here says Joan is not simply that, you know,
sometimes emotion wins of a reason. It's how easily it wins.
Seven numbers is all it takes to screw up reason. Just just,
just think about how astonishingly limited that is. Yeah,
I mean compared to a motion team reason is well,
pretty feeble and there's no way around it and we can kind of rage against the
machine. But the brute fact is it's just one microchip and a big computer.
And when we always rely on it,
all the advice and decision making is stop and think. Slow down, take your time.
And yet when you actually look at the brain, um,
that that can lead you to rely on a feeble piece of machinery. All right,
let me just offer it.
Admittedly in consequential case in point there we were at the Berkeley bowl in
the apple ion, there were thousands and thousands of apples to choose from.
Okay. Not Down but a lot and Robert and I get in our heads,
we're going to choose,
let's each choose an apple and Robert Being Robert decides like in six seconds
because it had this really cool name, Washington Pacific road. Zack,
I'm going to get this as me. I deliberate yet
maybe I should do it. Let's go to the organic. We're running out of time.
I lined up about 12 apples, compare them by rice size, color,
anything I can think of and eventually decided on a giant Korean apple pair,
which was the only logical choice because it was bigger than his.
This is a nine pound app check. It is large. It was more expensive too.
89 check. Definitely way more original
check in. I figure as we're checking out game,
I am the winner.
But a couple hours later we get to the airport,
we have some time before our flight. I grab a plastic knife and cut the apples.
Do a taste. Okay. [inaudible] two three.
And guess who's apple is the best. I'm guessing this as apple. Oh,
much better apple. Ah hmm. So good.
Apple wins in every department. Gone. My Apple.
I don't even want to talk about why this doesn't taste like an apple at all.
It has a surprise. Was it a worm? That's a gigantic core.
Is that a core version? An animal living there anyhow,
according to Jonah where I went wrong. Yeah, you've used complete,
you've short circuited your prefrontal cortex there.
The prefrontal Cortex is the right here in your forehead and that's where the
irrational brain lives.
And I just had given it to many things to keep track of all these apples.
You can only hold so much data at one month, you know, any given moment. Um, so,
so you can fix it on seven apples,
but only one piece of information for each apple. How red they are or are shiny.
They are.
So you can't do seven apples with seven variables because then you've got 4,909
that's a weight. Exactly. But there is a bigger problem than brain fatigue.
If you asked Barry Schwartz,
and it happens after you choose your plague with the possibility that you didn't
do as well as you, you could don't regret. I'm lamenting what could have been,
hey rich,
I definitely felt at the airport and chances are you didn't do as well as you
could. Well does it? Therein lies the Rub. And if of a place like Berkeley Bowl,
you get seduced by an 11 pound apple that turns out to be a fake watermelon with
an anus. All right, so,
oh, we now understand the problem that Barry proposes.
He says that if you have to make a choice to often the choice is the wrong one
cause your brain is too full of fat and hurts your head, your head,
or because if you make the choice, you then think, Ah Damn,
I should've chosen otherwise. The regret problem, right?
There are ways to handle this. Our friend Oliver sacks,
Dr. Oliver Sacks and euro scientists at irregular on this program.
We were talking and I told him about this issue and he said,
I don't have the problem. What do you mean you don't have the problem as well?
I make,
he says a willful choice that certain things I care about a lot and I worry over
it. And then others, all whole swath of my life that I just don't choose.
Yes. My housekeeper actually comes tomorrow and uh,
she will get half a gallon of soy milk,
half a gallon of prune juice and she will make a gallon or so of all ins.
Jello is, she will make a large bowl of Tabouli.
She will get six or seven tins of sardines because I eat sardines with two every
evening she would get seven apples in seven oranges, seven apple.
Why seven apples and seven. Okay.
Well because I'm also very greedy and impulsive and therefore I have to have a
rule that I am permitted to eat an a day and a
pair a day. Um, if I had 70 apples, I wa I, I would,
I would eat them all.
So you have worked it out so that you are regulating yourself and somehow your
appetite has become unregulated in the meantime? Yes.
I never get bored with my food. Why not? That seems so boring.
Well, it, it, um, I don't find it boring. I am,
I enjoy it equally with equal Vallish every time.
If I were to sit down with you and describe to you a new candy, I don't know,
almond m and m's and I were to do it with all the talents that I could possibly
bring to description. So you would see the Nice Outer Candy Shell.
It would glisten, it would be sugary,
it would have this most delicious nut inside.
Would you not feel at all tempted to break the habit of years,
whatever your sweet is and just venture over to almond m and. M?
I would certainly try the almond m and. M,
but since you mentioned it with chocolate, there is a shop close to me,
which has broken 72% chocolate.
I go there each day. Um, indeed, I have a,
you with me, a single dollar in my pocket,
put that down and I say a dollars worth of 72 every day. Every day.
Neither more nor less.
Can you recall the moment when you somehow leaped from whatever your predecessor
chocolate routine was to these 72% a cocoa content?
Something wonderful must've happened on that day where you got yanked from the
deep Rut that you are in into the next deep rut. But I'm just curious what,
what happened on the day of change? I don't, I don't clearly recollect,
but I can tell you a day of negative change.
This again goes back to my carnivorous days when I got a thing about kidneys.
For some reason, you mean the Oregon or the p? No,
no. The, the organ hung on, you know, on you.
It was when I was at wisdom to at UCLA and I am as I now have sardines every
time for dinner. At that time, living in Topanga Canyon,
I would have kidneys and I would go to the farmer's market and I would buy my
weekly kidneys. But on one occasion, a strange mistake happened,
whether I made the mistake or whether I was misheard, I all,
instead of my usual two pounds of kidneys, I was given 22 pounds of killers.
And if a mistake has made, I'm too shy to say anything.
And I do embarrass to be such a Wimp, both of routine and of shyness. I mean,
I think it's a double, it's a double duty there. Yes. Wow. Well, what the hell?
Anyhow, with these, I should of course a thrown away, uh,
this monstrous palpitating bag of kidneys.
Um,
but in the event I took it back to my little house in Topanga and then followed
an increasingly nightmarish period, um, in which I had kidneys for breakfast,
for lunch, kidneys stewed cares, sweet kidneys.
And finally, after about 10 days, by which time I'd eaten about 50 pounds.
I, I,
I'm an uncontrollable nausea and vomiting took a hold of me.
I literally are just the mind. Um, I think it was literally as well,
because I remember seeing bits of kidney and the format,
and I then threw out the west of the kidneys. And I've never had a kidney since
[inaudible]
Oliver sacks off author. Okay.
Most recently the book Musicophilia
[inaudible].
What did he call those kidneys? Just bring younger. What is that?
That's French for kidney. Really? Yeah. Yeah. Really? No kidding.
What's French for? Let's go to break. Oh five wow. Wow. No, but that's,
that's good bye for good meeting. We'll be right back. Okay. Coming up,
we have a story you will not believe about what happens behind the scenes at a
casino when you are trying not to lose, but nonetheless we're getting gouged.
That's coming up behind radio lab. I'm Jad Abumrad.
I remembered Krulwich stay with us.
Message one. Hi, this is Barry Schwartz.
Radio lab is funded in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation.
The corporation for public broadcasting and the National Science Foundation
Radio lab is produced by Wny C and distributed by national public radio by
and this message.
Hi, I'm Abby Jacobson
and you may know me from my fifth TV show, broad city,
but before that I went to art school. And why am I telling you that? Well,
it's because I have a podcast baby about art.
It's called a piece of work. It's a collab between me, w NYC studios and Moma.
I'll talk art with some of my friends like Questlove, Tavi, Gevinson,
and RuPaul, and we'll consult some experts and learn some incredible things.
Listen
to a piece of work with Abby Jacobson, wherever you get your podcasts.
Hello, I'm Chad up. I'm Ron and I remember crawling. This is radio lab.
Today's program is about choice. Yep.
How we choose why and wants his choice.
Shoes. I'm actually, I'm going to dream of a,
of the possibility one day of walking into a store and instead of being obsessed
and turned on by the beauty of an object or by the promise of an object or price
price of an Android,
the status that would be conferred upon me if I chose or not conferred upon me,
all those messy emotions. What would happen if I could be like, oh,
spot. I am half ball cannon ball canyons. Do not. I speak
from pure logic.
[inaudible]
hello. Hi. Hi. Hi, Jared and Robert.
We actually put the spot question to a neurologist,
Dr Antwan Beshara who works at the University of Southern California.
If I could say Abracadabra and go all logic,
would I be a happy
the chooser? Uh,
I would say no based on, uh,
our work with neurological patients in,
he told us about a patient he was had he's changed the name of the patient he
was, he would call them Elliott [inaudible]. Can you, can you describe him?
What was he like? Yeah. Wow. He's about five feet, uh, 10, you know,
170 pounds I would say. And what did that kind of decree? It looks very normal,
like a normal
Bursa. He was an accountant. That's [inaudible] again for a large corporation,
successful accountant, upper management and active in his local church.
And he was married?
Yes, a very conservative family. Very religious house in the suburbs,
good money savings, smart, successful man.
Kind of the American dream.
And then, you know, the tumor happened.
This is in 1982 doctors discovered a small knot in the front of Elliot's head
and a part of the brain called the org glow frontal cortex.
And where's that dance? Just behind the eyes to doctors removed the tumor.
Yeah, he had the surgery, the tumor was removed
and then the doctors send them home. Well, at first glance,
it seems like a tremendous success. No language impairment,
no movement disorders.
He still score 97th percentile on the intelligence test. Um, he's, he,
he seems fine. Like good old Elliot does good old Elliott.
Go back to the good old jobs. He starts going back to the good old job,
the good old family. And that's when things got really weird that,
that at first it's just subtle things. These very minor decisions did.
He suddenly couldn't make, like he'd be at the office,
he'd want to sign a contract and he'd have in front of him a blue pen and a
black pen and he would think, well, type on this contract is black,
so maybe I should use a blue pen. Maybe a blue pen sticks out more.
On the other hand, maybe 600 too much and will become too distracting.
Then again, black pen is lower on ink, so you want to save that for later.
I just would go on an on set Jonah or half an hour
if it takes him a half an hour to decide which pin to choose.
Imagine Elliot in the cereal aisle in the grocery store.
I mean this year last particularly tough because there, yeah,
there must be 200 varieties of cereal. This is a sugary cereal.
This is a not sugary. Susannah. I think about it, you know,
what would I prefer tomorrow when with extra proof I've got these other cereals
at home.
Are they also hunting up the [inaudible] to break up the honey nut monotony?
Is there one cereal on sale? That's a better deal with Elliot.
It'll take forever to decide. According to Dr Bashar,
he would just keep on analyzing, analyzing this one's 14 hours
analyzing 15 ounces,
but for the standard prices they also analyzing on analyzing is is the one
certainly analyzing
all day long.
The question was what exactly had happened to Elliot to make him that way?
What exactly did that tumor do?
And the breakthrough came when Elliot went to see a neurologist named Antonio
Demasio into Mazda. Immediately noticed something,
even though Elliott was perfectly thoughtful, perfectly articulate,
always controlled, always relaxed. When he spoke, he seemed kind of numb.
No sign of anger or rage or self-pity, no feeling at all.
So demasio had an idea. He put Elliot in a chair,
hooked him up to all these measuring devices and then showed Elliot a series of
really charged pictures,
severed foot and naked woman house on fire pictures.
At a normal people trigger an automatic emotional response. You can't help it,
but your blood pressure increases. Your pulse increases,
your hands start to sweat. But with Elliot,
these pictures triggered nothing and that's when it became clear what had
happened to Elliott would,
his tumor had really done with cut him off from his emotional mind.
He'd become ineffective. I'm kind of like Spock leg Vulcan
[inaudible].
The conventional theory would be that a person without emotions would be
perfectly rational.
[inaudible]
that emotion somehow interfered with rationality that they got in the way.
Here's this guy who couldn't experience emotions and he would pathologically
indecisive. So then the answer to my question, my first question,
wouldn't we all be better off if we could be completely rational? You know,
have the answer. It's no.
When you got all these options to consider and they're more or less the same,
the only way to wheedle your way to a choice is to stop thinking and go with,
go with a feeling. Right? And so the, the, the logic of yes,
no, yes, no, yes. No leads you nowhere but the feelings of yes.
No, yes, no, that does lead you somewhere. That's right. Feeling.
So zantoine Beshara that's the key. Without feeling
you're stuck. So what ended up happening to Elliot? You ended up in a divorce,
uh, and ended up losing his job, losing all his savings.
He got involved with the con artist. Um,
you have to move back in with his parents. Elliott was stuck. His, his,
his life fell apart,
which makes you kind of reevaluate the doctors' spark advantage.
So called because if we really were keeping company with a,
a flock of Spock's and we brought them to the grocery store there,
they'd be 55 sparks staring at the Cheerios, the Cheerios,
not to mention that they're divorced and broke.
So I mean obviously we have some advantage over these welcomes cause we have
these feelings that can push us to the solution. Yeah. But what I,
what I still don't get as,
is it just the roar of feeling that does it or is there something about having a
feeling
that's more subtle than that? That is, is there some, is there some,
what is the power of the feeling? That's an interesting question. Let me,
let me get, let me walk this story in from a writer, Stephen Johnson.
So he's written a whole bunch of books, emergence, mind wide open, cool.
And he tells this story that can we press record really gets at what you're
asking.
My wife and I had moved into this new wonderful apartment that overlooked the
Hudson, a river on the west side of Manhattan. It had this vast window.
It was one kind of window in this room, but it was huge.
And we would sit there and stare out at the river all times a day.
And at one point, the first time where we were there,
the storm started to come in and they were to kind of build up over Jersey and
come rolling in. And we thought, oh, this is great.
We can look at the white caps on it and see the lightning over in Jersey City
and all this stuff. And one late June day,
we're sitting out there in our apartment,
we can see the guy's getting darker and darker and we immediately say to each
other how this is going to be a great yeah
show. So we have to over to the window and we, uh, we're standing at the window.
My wife literally with her hands pressed against the glass and I'm standing
right next to it, just to the side of it, kind of looking out.
And a storm starts really kicking up.
There's a lot of lightning and you can see the window actually kind of flex just
a tiny little bit, which is, so you noticed this when? Yeah, we noticed that,
that there was a little bit of give in and we know that size,
it has to have a little bit of Gif,
otherwise it's not stable so we can tell it was really,
it was really windy and um,
and there are a couple of pretty powerful gusts and then all of a sudden there's
this very strange sharp kind of click sound.
My wife instantly jumps back from the window, jumps back, you know,
kind of four or five feet and says, what was that?
I say being the incredibly perceptive person that I am. I say,
I'm pretty sure it was the study door slamming with the wind around the corner
in the, in the other part of the apartment.
So she goes back around the corner to check on whether it was in fact the study
door slamming.
And at that moment as I'm standing two inches from the frame and the window,
the entire thing. Yeah.
Hello.
It makes insane noise. It shatters glass. Wow.
And all of a sudden there's a, you know,
60 mile an hour storm like blowing through our hearts
[inaudible]
so we both run into the bathroom and close the door and all of a sudden,
you know, I suddenly think like, oh my God,
you were standing in front of that window three seconds before. If,
if I hadn't stupidly told you that I thought that clicking sound was the door
slamming, nothing would've landed on you.
I think it's entirely possible that it would've killed her. Okay.
So that that happened. His wife by the way was fine. Good.
They installed a new window. They cleaned up the apartment.
They did because I am covered with imaginary glass.
I mean I sad to fix it so unbelievably Rio,
thank you very much.
But what's illuminating and what gets at the question you asked yes.
Is actually what happened next.
It's the postscript to that event for literally years.
Every time I heard the sound of wind blowing through a window in that apartment
and really pretty much anywhere else I had an involuntary fear reflects the
sound of any wind or is it a specific kind of wind sound? Uh,
it was a sound of wind associated with a window. So you know, it's the,
okay,
you know,
I would go to my parents' house who live on the ground floor of the house in
suburban Washington,
but I would just hear when kind of going through the window there and I would
think something's not right and this was not a rational feeling.
It was certainly not a rational thought.
I could look empirically and say it's 30 miles an hour. This wind,
the window is clearly not going to blow in.
It's not that big a window and I'm standing nowhere near it.
But you still somehow couldn't shake the dread.
I couldn't get rid of that feeling.
And it's one of those moments where you really, you really ask yourself,
I think you know who's in charge, you know who's driving the ship, you know,
because some part of me is looking at this situation in PuroClean Zang,
rationally this window is no threat to me, right? It's not going to blow in.
And yet some other part of me is unable to shake this emotional state of,
of dread and fear and alertness and threat. All right.
Now to get back to your question Robert, where do feelings come from? Yeah,
why do I say yes to weak checks with, with uh, with power, right?
We'll consider the,
the story we just heard from the perspective of a Steven Johnson's brain. Okay.
So what a brain wants to do most of all is keep the organisms safe, right?
And it does that by looking for patterns. Like here's an explosion.
Life almost died.
Like it's entirely possible that it would have killed her in that moment.
Brain soaks it all in. Takes kind of a snapshot. Like what do we got here?
Window,
glass shock till the later wind blows brain thinks need a second window class.
We've seen this before. Warn the organism. Be Afraid, be afraid, be afraid.
My point is that feeling of dread and fear and alertness and threat,
that's just an alarm signal.
The brain is just trying to help Steve make the right decision. Great.
Okay. Now under the cereal out there you are. You're looking at all the boxes,
captain crime, and as your eyes fall on the right's crispy box, right?
Rice krispies race me just like Steve Johnson with the wind somewhere way deep
down,
your brain is calling up all the experiences you've ever had with Rice krispies,
the good rice crispy experiences, the bad ones.
Maybe in college you got dumped by that girl who likes Rice Krispie treats.
I don't know. I remember her thousands of little memory fragments down there.
Royal about a lot of information, I think too much.
So what ends up happening is that it all gets summed somehow in your
subconscious and then it bubbles up as a feeling crispies.
All right.
So one way to look at a gut feeling is that it's a kind of shorthand average of
all of this past wisdom.
[inaudible].
So you have this tremendous Sturman drawn the feelings in the Centerman.
Whoa, that's a German, I could do it a little jerky now,
but there is a scientist,
one feeling that humans have that seems to Trump all the others and that is the
feeling of loss. People heat to lose. You can actually put a number on it,
how much they hate to lose versus winning.
And it's a really cool experiment that was done, but then I'd be everywhere.
But our experiment will be done by national public radio's wonderful reporter
Mike Peskov.
Are you a bit of a gambler or would you rather just keep your money and not risk
it? Um, I mean, I, I wouldn't mind risking a few dollars,
but I just don't want to go overboard. You know what you say? You're,
you're a gambling woman. You like gambling. No, I don't. I don't really gamble.
I, I'm very cautious and Finicky,
whether it's eating or taking chances. Yeah.
The risk of losing something isn't worth the gambling. I mean,
I guess I wouldn't take over and go, I played that way.
We were to play heads or towels. Would you want to do it if you won,
you want a dollar. But if I want, I wanted dollars. Probably not. No, no,
no thanks.
If you knew the game was on the up and up and I were to flip a coin and I said,
Oh look, I'll pay you, you know, a dollar 25 if you win,
you only have to pay me a dollar. I ain't doing it with, you know, I don't know.
That just doesn't seem worth it. I said, look,
I'll give you a dollar 50 and you only have to put up a dollar.
Would you do it then? No, not really.
50 cents is not worth if I offered you a dollar 75 if you want the possibility,
maybe like at that point you maybe start thinking, fine, I'll give you $2.
You only have to put up a dollar. Would you be interested? Sure. Yeah.
I would do that. I would do that. Yes, sure. Wow.
So everyone seems to converge around two bucks. Two to one. Yes.
So that means that like losses twice is painful. Yeah.
You could say loss hurts twice as much as gain. Feels good.
Why do you think that is? It must have something to do with, you know,
when we were all running away from lions on the Savannah. Yeah.
It always seems to come back to that, doesn't it? Oh,
I guess a Willdabeast in the brush is worth a lion on the heels or something.
No. Know what that means.
But were there any people that you talked to who went way past two to one? Sure.
Okay. A hundred to one. No. Come on. You're crazy. A hundred at two.
One on a coin. [inaudible] nope. Nope. I'm just not a gambler.
Is this a religious thing? No, I'm just not a gambler.
So here's the question to get us to the next thing. Wow.
Given that human beings hate to lose,
what do you do if your entire business is getting people to lose money?
You're talking about. He knows that you're not, dude,
I am here going to Las Vegas highway, Lennox City, lantack city.
Then I normally would have seen it will do,
and they will try to distract you with, you know,
fountains of Jellybeans and Regan statues that move.
But there's one casino in particular called Harris.
It's a chain that doesn't do any of that. Yeah,
they offer slots and they offer a blackjack, but there's no exploding volcano.
There's no Picasso on the wall yet, according to Mike Harris jumps out at you.
They are the success story in the casino base.
Gary Loveman has a lot to do with that. Yeah. Any minute.
You're not drunk or depressed, I'd like you in the casino.
He's the CEO of Harris Casinos casino business,
and he's developed a really brilliant technique for slaying the beast.
That is loss aversion. That's one way to put it. What's his technique?
Loyalty cards. What's a loyalty card? What does that mean? Well, basically,
I mean, you know how back in the day, if you wanted to play the slots,
you just stuck a quarter in [inaudible] can't do that anymore. Right.
You're like, I'd like to, I'd like to throw a quarter in the one armed bandit.
Turns out there are no quarters. Okay,
I'll slide a dollar bill and it turns out before you have to do it,
you have to sign up for a card. Well, why would I want to sign up for a card?
Well, hey, you have to, but B, the first time you play,
we'll give you a couple extra dollars. Everyone wants to sign up for that card.
It's free money. Now, just to be clear at Harris,
it's actually not obligatory to sign up for this card,
but most people do to get the rewards. And so there you are.
You've got this little loyalty thing and you're sticking it in every slot or
machine that you play. Mat offers them certain, uh,
well they've got this new pilot program where they basically watch every move
you make. Hm. Check it out. Okay.
Let's say you're playing the slots. Okay?
You stick your card in the slot machine. All right, Mike,
Tireless in at that very moment,
the information is transmitted downstairs. In the case of this casino,
we were out. It goes downstairs in the bowels of the casino.
I need to take a four to Julia.
There was a dispatcher sitting there in front of a monitor.
This computer sees that you've put your card into slot machine number 42 four
seven 53 computer begins taking notes.
Every game that you play, they're logging on,
adding at a dividing line graph and graphics, whatever, whatever.
It's able to crunch those numbers and over many visits, the casino
begins to know you.
They know your game is slots and I know you'd like to play for an average of six
hours
and they know that generally you have a limit,
say $89 wow. They can know that I usually leave after losing 89 bucks
and you know on this particular visit you're not doing so well, right?
When you've lost more than you're winning. In fact, you've lost 72 box,
which is really close to your personal limit and this is the crucial moment
you're starting to get that sinking feeling. You might just pack it in.
I walk out of the Casino. Casino doesn't want you to do that.
They want to keep you there.
So as your loss increasing from 72 to 77 to 85 and you're getting closer and
closer to them in a back room,
there's a computer going off at dispatchers seeing it.
Juliet 37 Oh three the dispatcher knows to call the slot attendant up on the
floor. Go for Willie.
I have a DCL one at Gulf 14 oh for Karen Method
Willie Lisa, one for Kevin Massey cop and the slot attendant walks out.
Tap you on the shoulder. Hello. How you doing ma'am? Ms Kevin Massa. Yeah,
everything going okay for you today I'm losing.
Of course we know that's the case because our systems allows us to monitor that
and so the attendant offers you something you might like to visit to the steak
house and visit to our coffee shop. They could offer you tickets to a show,
Celine Dion's playing the big room. Woo. Or they could just offer cold,
hard cash once a money today just by playing with your car. You're lucky.
We're walking on. Really, I've, I got $15 DCL one point yet. We got seven
and all of a sudden you're happy that you won 15 bucks.
You're not fixated on the fact that you've lost 72 so you come back to again and
again and again. I think it's great if something to do,
I've always had was $300 off the day with the nerve.
Boys don't know how much.
Now here is the amazing part for all the different thousands of people who come
through the doors of Harris Casinos.
They could figure out their own individual pain points.
So you're telling me that if you walk into a casino,
I walk in right after you Robert Krulwich right after us. Yeah.
And we do that enough times.
After a while they can know that you like to gamble until you're about $700
down. Me, I usually get around 11 bucks and moneybags crow, which over there,
money back scroll, which usually holds out until he's for granted in the hall.
Right. And they can know that about each of us. Yeah, they can.
What do you think about this strikes you as a good business proposition or does
it strike you as a creepy example of big brother ism?
Obviously this works out well for Harris. So does it work out well for me?
You and Robert Krulwich? I think it does. What do you mean? Well,
they can ever change the odds. So when we go into a casino by state law,
they'll never be able to change the odds of the game.
All that Harris can do is kind of manage the feeling that we get.
Hmm.
They leave a lot happier than if they had simply had a bad gaming experience,
put their wallet back in their pocket and go on home on happy
and everything about going to the, to a casino is a poor decision,
an irrational decision.
And if there was a way they can make me walking out of there feeling like 1
million bucks when I spent 2 million, well then I say more power to them.
And I would add of course that almost any business could try something similar
as assuming they had appealing sorts of things to do for customers that had bad
experiences.
What's your pain point, by the way? Uh, you know what it is.
If I'm down 300 bucks, I'm really pissed off. I'm not going to get there. Yeah.
There's only one thing that would keep me at the table. That's it.
Celine Dion not, not tickets for a concert. If she was actually in the game.
She's a terrible poker player. What we call dead money.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
thanks Mike. Yeah, we'll be back.
Hey, by the way, Mike works at NPR news.
Thank you to them for letting us borrow him.
I am Candace Crotty calling from Saint Paul, Minnesota.
Radiolab is supported in part by the science foundation and by the Alfred p
Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hello, this is radio lab. I'm Jad Abumrad.
I am Robert Krulwich and today we are talking about decision making,
how we make decisions like Oh I want to just to stop you in that Pronoun you
just happened to you. You would say we make decisions now.
So when you get a boomer, when you decide to choose a pen black over blue,
if you decide to choose a cereal cheerio's over special k. Sure, yes,
definitely. Uh,
I'm assuming that you feel very much in charge of that choice. You know,
if someone said, hey, who chose, you'd say, this feels like a trick question.
It's going to be a trick question. You chose to cheerios.
Well you think you chose,
would you please welcome the Studley Malcolm Gladwell?
I'm talking with Malcolm Gladwell,
the writer of the tipping point and he at the time he'd just written to the book
blink. We were at the 92nd street Y in New York.
He raised an interesting question. Yes.
We began the discussion by talking about a dangerous element in decision making,
which he calls call this the perils,
that introspection and you tell the story of a poster contest.
It involves hanging cats versus,
do you recall this? Yes. Yeah. Yes. Gosh, I have no memory.
Um, the um, yeah, this is a famous study by, um, Tim Wilson,
who's one of my favorite psychologist at UVA and a guy named John Schooler who's
absolutely brilliant. They, uh,
they have a whole bunch of posters and they bring students in and they say,
take anyone you want, it's yours.
And then they bring in another group and they say, take any one you want,
but by the way, before you go home with it, um, just explain,
write out a paragraph about why you're taking it home, why you like it.
And then they call up the student six months later and they say,
that poster you got for free six months ago, do you like it?
Are you still happy with it?
And the ones who didn't have to explain themselves still love their poster and
the ones who did hate their poster. And furthermore,
the ones who had to explain themselves,
it turns out only took the posters of the hanging cats of the little kittens,
you know, hanging, they go hanging of cats. It doesn't mean like, but if, no,
no, no, no. You know those posters,
you surely you saw them or maybe you have lived in the upper kind of
intellectual precincts for so long that you lost contact with the rest of us.
But, um, you know, dove, you never seen them.
The little kitten hanging on a bar and it says, hang in there baby, you know?
Oh yeah. All right. I don't think of it as hanging. I forget.
It's sort of you're fake. You're just saying. Yeah, no we're not. Yeah,
you're right. You're right. I am taking it off. My, actually,
when I first saw that,
I thought that kitten was having to do a chin up and so it didn't have the
desired effect. I thought, why are they torturing this kid? Right.
Why do kittens have to work? Is it, you know,
is it not enough that human beings have to go to the gym anyway?
But you had those,
then you had impression as posters and the kids who had to explain their
preferences overwhelmingly chose the kittens and those who didn't have to
explain themselves chose the impressionist posters.
So what that says is the act of making you explain your preferences not only
biased you in favor of something, but you didn't actually want,
it also made you change your preference away from something that was
sophisticated and in favor of something that was unsuccessful.
[inaudible]
hmm
if you think about the whole universe of focus group testing and something that
determines all of the cultural products that get into our society,
that makes you really stop and worry, right?
We're putting people through a process that alienates them from their true needs
and that biases them in favor of the unsophisticated
[inaudible].
Well,
an overwhelming majority of the greatest and most successful movies or sitcoms
or television shows of all time tested badly, almost by definition.
They're really breakthrough shows will test badly in focus groups.
I actually saw the focus group results for Mary Tyler Moore show,
which were devastating. Hayden. Mary was abrasive.
Roto was, you know, noxious, you know the,
in the focus group testing of all in the family,
which got one of the lowest scores of any sick pilot, a tested CBS.
The overwhelming majority of people who watched the show said that the only way
to fix it was to turn Archie into a kind of cuddly, sensitive,
you know, it's crazy. It's crazy.
The only reason these shows ever make on the areas that somebody at some point
just says, you know what? Ignore that stuff. I like it.
[inaudible]
so the, the suggestion here is that because these snap judgments are,
are eight mysterious over explained,
therefore corrected in the wrong direction. Frankly, capitalists,
capitalism should have no cutting edge excitement except that there are these
occasional people's take the risk at the system. So that's one, one consequence.
The other though is very, very much interesting to me. Um,
if you can't know why you have a feeling in your gut and you can't explain why
you have a feeling in your gut,
and to some extent you can't control what's the feeling in your gut. You,
you wonder who's in charge of the choices that you make.
And there's a whole section of this book, which is maybe the scariest,
which is about something called priming, where external clues things that you,
um, see trigger biases inside you. So let me run you through some of those. Uh,
there's a game you ask your readers to play. We have play.
They are words in the game. And the, in one of the Games you played,
the words wrinkle, Bingo and Florida appear matter of factly.
What happens to people who see
while doing something else, wrinkle Bingo and Florida,
they walk out of the room after the test is over more slowly than they walked
into the,
you ask people to play a game of trivial pursuit. Some of them you say, first,
before we play this game,
let's think about professors for a moment and now we'll play trivial pursuit.
In other group you say, let's play trivial pursuit,
but now let's think about soccer hooligans and then we'll play trivial pursuit.
What's the difference if I make you think about professors first,
your scores are substantially superior. You win. Basically.
If I make you think about hooligans, you lose just thinking about them. Yes.
[inaudible]
can we step away from the 92nd street y for just a moment here. Um,
cause this priming thing that you and Malcolm are discussing gets Kinda Uri when
you go actually beyond words like here. Um, once you have a sip of this coffee,
this coffee here. Yeah, right now. Yeah. Let's go ahead and have a sit.
Why he looking at me like that? Because I've just primed you. What do you mean?
Cause I have just primed you. You were just, what crime do you think you mean?
I to explain it. We talked to a psychologist.
My name is John Barge and I'm a professor at Yale University in Psychology
Department and John did an interesting experiment. Okay. Check one,
two in a Grad student by the name of Lawrence Williams. Here's what they did.
Lawrence went out into the world and get a bunch of stuff with them and
briefcase some coffees and papers,
so much stuff that he could barely carry it all. And he went out,
went out into the in front of the library or in town,
and he would approach somebody and he'd say, excuse me, sir, ma'am,
would you mind taking this survey? It's just a minute of your time,
but give their agreement to be in the study grades. Pretty simple survey.
What kind of survey? Well,
it had a picture of a guy on it and a description of the guy who's got the guy's
name was Joe. So here's Joe. Joe. Joe Is these six traits.
There's a little description of Joe right there on the paper. Okay.
I want you to do, he would say, all I want you to do for this surveys.
Just tell me gut feeling. What do you think a Joe, do you like him?
That's it. That's it. Do I like how much do you like Joe? That's,
that's the whole question. Yeah,
you mean like rate it one to ten one to 10 and everyone saw the same person.
Describe the same way. Everyone sees the same description,
but there's one thing I haven't told you yet.
Somewhere in this process toward the beginning you would ever so casually ask
them, can you just do me a favor? My hands are full.
Can you hold this Cup of coffee? Your hold this just for a second. Thanks.
And they just take it for a second. It's all very natural.
So it's not even seen as part of the experiment because it was just a second.
Well, I should say it. Yeah. Everybody got the same cup of coffee. In fact,
he would hand half the people a cup of hot coffee and you would hand the other
half a cup of iced coffee like I gave you. And it was always really fast.
They only hold the cup for maybe a second at most, but that second,
whether it was hot or cold, seems to have made a, because the hot coffee people,
both people who saw, who had touched the or held the hot coffee
when they were asked, do you like Joe? The majority said, yeah, exactly.
They liked Joe. Where's the cold coffee people? By and large,
they didn't like him. Oh cool. Is that right?
I just bank very, very bad kid. You know, they've repeated this study many,
many times. Always the same result.
People who hold the hot coffee are more pro Joe than the people who hold the ice
coffee. In other words, something happens in that second when they hold the cup,
some sort of mistranslation in their brain where warm cup becomes warm.
Joe Real warm.
This physical sensation gets confused with the metaphor.
People are all the same temperature, usually 98.6 degrees.
We're not different in warmth and cold physically,
but we talk about people that way. It's very important to us.
You hear somebody who's warm, you immediately like them.
You hear a person's cold, you know you don't want to be their friend.
You don't want to hire them. Warmth.
And Colton is psychologically is all about trust.
[inaudible]
it's all about are you a friend or a foe?
lovely. So why wouldn't it? Why would, if that, but if that's true,
why is it true? Like why, why the confusion? Yeah.
Why does it boil down to something as dumb as that? Well,
John Barge and his team have actually been, uh, asking that question,
doing some neuroscience to see if maybe the inside the brain they can see
something that would explain it. Yeah.
And it seems that the, the area of the brain that records temperature a bit,
it's responsive to actual physical temperature is also the same area of the
brain that is, uh, the location of where, uh,
I'll trust the same little part of the brain is got both of those things going
on
and he thinks that there is a good reason for that.
Temperature and trust are in fact link,
particularly when you're a little baby.
Since our first learning about the world is,
is usually in terms of what we can see and what we can touch.
We don't have much memory and we can't think very well.
So it's all about our immediate experience.
While a huge important area of experience for a little baby is to,
is to keep close to the caretaker and to stay warm.
I mean this,
this is something that's so critical when they're so tiny and helpless that they
don't maintain closeness. If they don't maintain warmth, they don't survive.
So, uh, I guess the, the,
the point is if you're hiring somebody and it,
and you really want to hire the right person, don't have any coffee around,
but the first step is to accept the possibility. And very few people believe me,
I tried to explain to my family and my friends what I do.
And they never believe any of these things are really true of them because we
don't have any awareness of them.
I can't remember one time that ever happened to me. Well, yeah,
you won't remember one time because it's never going to be in your memory.
It's never going to be in your awareness. Yeah. I, it's time. I don't, why
is it so hard for us to, to, um,
to concede that a huge part of our own motivations
are mysterious. We're back now at the 92nd street y again with Malcolm Gladwell.
I have to say there was a part of our conversation where this whole thing got a
little scary to me.
You have to do in part with race because instead of using hot and cold as the
metaphor, suppose you use black or white. Right. And he said very flatly.
There are stereotypes that we have that seem to be beyond our ability to
control. In fact,
he took a test to measure the unconscious feelings that he had in him about
black and white
people. I score on an unconscious,
turns out I have a moderate preference for whites on an unconscious level and he
is by the way half black. Um, yeah.
Which is not unusual for black people by the way. Um, nor is it unusual for,
you know,
Jews to have a moderate unconscious preference for gentiles over Jews or for any
kind of, um, with blacks? It's most striking. Uh,
my unconscious attitudes towards blacks are a function of the society in which I
live. My unconscious is basically x is just basically collecting impressions and
thoughts and biases and stuff from the world.
I live in amassing this massive database.
And if in an a very kind of unfiltered way, right. Well my data,
my unconscious database about race has more negative things about blacks in it
than positive things. Right. I live in, you know, the United States,
of course it does. And so the, of course it's not going to not affect me,
you know? Well
yeah, it's just, it's horrible. Or maybe just put it this way,
that, that, uh,
that you can't really purge yourself of things that would bother you if you
could spy on them and that you are in some sense a prisoner of your culture in a
way that makes you in some way.
Ungovernable you can't quite get on top of yourself.
No. The more you push, I mean,
I don't push this issue that far in the book cause it gets really troubling
really quickly. Yeah, it does. The more you push it to you, right.
It's deeply disturbing. And there's a book written by, um, uh,
a guy named Daniel Wagner at Harvard called the illusion of conscious will,
um, which, and it's a very difficult book. Um,
but if he pushes this as far as you go, and you know, at the end,
if you go through all of this research, it's pinned down recently in psychology,
you do end up with the position that the notion of conscious will is an
illusion.
It's just we make up stories that make it make us feel good about the decisions
we make, but in fact,
we're not really as nearly as in charge as we think we are.
A
[inaudible].
That was Malcolm Gladwell talking with me at the 92nd street y.
His new book is called outliers. Anything you heard this hour,
you can hear again on our website, radio lab.org. While you're there,
send us an email. Radiolab at Wny C. Dot. Org is the dress I'm chat up. Boom.
Rod, I'm Robert Krulwich. Thanks for listening.